are you tired of playing pokemon go on  your fancy new smartphone if you want to  play it on a retro console I've got the  answer I'm Tony and this is your dreamy  GameSpot news update a modder by the  name of guac asaurus Mex is developing  Pokemon go vmu as the name implies it's  a version of the hit mobile game for the  sega dreamcast visual memory unit  considering the device launched in 1998  some changes have been made such as the  removal of gps functionality instead  you'll be playing the game on a randomly  generated grid still porting a modern  game to an 18-year old device is quite  impressive Pokemon go vmu is slated for  launch in 2017 guac asaurus Mex says  there's a weight quote because I'm lazy  and it's going to take forever to draw  all those damn Pokemon in the meantime  the Mater has some other games available  for the vmu including flappy bird and  Street race to keep up with all the  crazy mods and video game lands you're  already in the right place  you